[Music]
[Music]
good afternoon my name is Earl Berman on
behalf of the Department of aeronautics
and Astronautics of the Massachusetts
Institute of Technology and the New
England section of the American
Institute of Aeronautics and
Astronautics I'd like to welcome you to
the 25th lester gardner lecture
Lester Gardner was a graduate of the
class of 1898 an air officer in World
War one publisher of aviation literature
a leader of the aeronautics profession
and enthusiast for aeronautical
engineering in his will he bequeathed
the gift to sponsor an annual lecture on
the history of aeronautics with today's
lecture marking the 25th anniversary
year of the landing on the moon we
expand in the theme of Lester Gardner
lecture to include astronautics if
Academy Awards were to be given for this
1/2 century's greatest achievements the
Apollo program certainly would be
nominated for an Oscar and today's
speakers would be nominated for the best
producer and the best leading performer
dr. Robert C Siemens jr. researcher
engineer skillful administrator
professor Dean of engineering and
outstanding gentlemen will be the first
speaker a graduate of Harvard and MIT
dr. Siemens joined NASA's associate
administrator in 1960 after research and
teaching at the instrumentation lab now
the Charles stark Draper laboratories at
MIT and five years with RCA in his
position as associate administrator and
then deputy administrator of NASA until
1968 he oversaw the historic mercury and
Gemini and Apollo programs after leaving
NASA he served as Secretary of the Air
Force president of the National Academy
of Engineering administrator of the
energy research and development
administration agency and professor and
Dean of engineering at MIT
his lovely wife Jean is partner for 52
years during this illustrious career is
also with us today Jean
[Applause]
midway through this lecture dr. Siemens
will pass the podium to Neil Armstrong
engineer combat and test pilot astronaut
professor businessman and role model for
a generation of youth around the world a
graduate of Purdue and USC mr. Armstrong
joined NASA as a test pilot after
serving in Korea in 1962 he transferred
to the astronaut corps it was a
commander in 1966 of the Gemini 8 flight
the first to accomplish docking in space
his Gemini partner was David Scott a
graduate of our department here at MIT
mr. Armstrong is known throughout the
world for the words that's one small
step for a man one giant step for
mankind which he spoke as the first
human to step on the moon on July 20th
1969 his hiking partner on the Apollo 11
expedition dr. Buzz Aldrin jr. also a
graduate of our department is here with
us today Buzz
after late after leaving NASA sorry buzz
I have to cut off the applause after
leasing leaving NASA in 1971 Neil has
been a professor of aerospace
engineering at the University of
Cincinnati and as president presently
chairman of ail Systems Incorporated
electronics manufacturer twenty-five
years ago the attention of the world was
focused on a race to put man on the moon
such a feat seemed unbelievable to most
humans today mankind debates the wisdom
of man space program and the priorities
for its funding but since Neil and Buzz
walked on the moon how many times have
we all heard someone say if we can put a
man on the moon why can't we whatever
the problem is the Apollo program stands
as the benchmark for what mankind can
accomplish and a challenge to all those
who follow today we will hear just how
difficult this challenge was as our
speakers tell us about engineering
aspects of a lunar landing please join
me in welcoming dr. Siemens to the
podium
[Applause]
thank you
Neal and I flipped the coin I'm going to
take the left-hand side he's going to
take the right it's certainly a
certainly a great honor for me to to be
involved with the Gardiner lecture and
to be on the podium with Neil and I can
honestly say that that wouldn't it
wouldn't have happened if it hadn't been
for my my former boss my my first boss
my mentor for for 15 years here at the
Institute person by the name of dr. a /
now doc on occasion used to use the
analogy of fire engines their power
their speed their energy when Air Force
or Navy brass complete with entourage
use would visit the lab he'd say we're
nothing but little boys on the sidewalk
watching the fire engines go by and at
this point I'm going to show you what
doctor like to do best doc love to work
with equipment he also like people but
nothing nothing better for Doc than to
and to have a new design coming along
but to test it to try it to take it up
at an airplane or put it through its
paces and here you see my my my mentor
dr. Draper up on the roof of his
laboratory checking out the guidance and
navigation system that was to be used
going to the moon and in the distance
you can recognize the Longfellow bridge
you can see the Prudential building now
now in the in the late 1950s NASA
reminded me very much of Doc's analogy
Keith Glennon the fire chief up front
Bob Gilruth there he was manning the
life-support vehicle for the seven
astronauts Wernher von Braun was driving
a hook and ladder fortunately he had a
Baha'i Driss
back in the rear the hook and lanta to
keep on the road he was a chief engineer
other engines were driven by people like
Abe silverstein and tommy Thompson and
all the various directors and
and program managers there were a lot of
engines and there were a lot of fires to
put out now I was one of the small boys
watching the a minor approached one day
and said I wish and I was aboard when
all of a sudden
Keith Glennon who the fire chief he
swerved over to the curb and he opened
the door and he invited me to ride along
with him and dr. Dryden you know asked
about you know what's really going on
what's the rush why all this energy what
capabilities were needed before
obtaining all the answers Keith left and
Jim Webb became the chief the fire
intensified it was no longer merely a 10
alarm fire new facilities and kinds of
equipment were required we had only only
eight years to meet a major deadline of
landing men on the moon and returning
them safely to earth now we know we met
those met the deadline below sometimes
I'll have to admit when I see the moon
coming up over the horizon I really
wonder if it actually happened and I
also find it find it sometimes hard to
believe that it took place 25 years ago
I mean Neil and Buzz haven't changed a
bit
but the magnitude of the effort required
to achieve this goal was so great that
no single person could possibly observe
the total endeavor I say this because
there may be differing views of the
mission and so on could after all there
were 400,000 people involved and there
were many different jobs to be done now
you're about to hear two accounts
discussing the program from an
engineering standpoint when I joined
NASA in the late summer of 1960 the
agency was four hundred million dollars
apart from from President Eisenhower's
view of what we should be getting Keith
Glennon met with Maurice Stan's director
of OMB soon after I arrived to reclaimer
60 million of the 400 million difference
stands left at the idea
in desperation Keith's eyes what do you
want in space and Stan's replied
a bargain-basement figure 1.09 billion
sometime later at a cabinet meeting
Joyce Castilla Kowski who was the
present science advisor presented the
result of a study that indicated the
cost of man lunar landing would be
between twenty and forty billion dollars
after the gasping subsided around the
table Eisenhower said I wish someone
could tell me the best 1 billion dollar
program for space after Jim Webb became
chief I joined him in a visit to the new
director of OMB Dave Bell we made a
pitch for Saturn boosters in the Apollo
manned exploration beyond the existing
man operating on a shoestring mercury
when we proposed design studies for
Apollo there was no sale and it was no
sale a few days later when we met with
President Kennedy
however Gagarin's flight around the
world in 1 hour and 48 minutes of much
late a month later raised anew the
question why was the USA so far behind
the Congress went crazy looking for a
scapegoat
why wasn't NASA working 24 hours a day
to get ahead of the Soviets and let me
say at that time people were working
down here 24 hours a day to get mercury
into orbit President Kennedy had wanted
to hear the evidence before weighing in
on new space initiatives however the
evidence had become clear whether by
luck or careful planning the Soviets had
scored big in the international arena
and Kennedy didn't propose hauling up
the white flag but what or which goals
would permit the u.s. to gain greater
respect in future years some counseled
against further manned space in favor of
intensified scientific research here on
earth or in space Kennedy reached out
beyond the staff to Vice President
Johnson and ultimately to McNamara
secretary defense and a Jim Webb for the
answers now if I can find the right
button here we go
what you have here is that that mercury
vehicle up on top of the redstone
booster this was this was really a wing
and a prayer type operation of it it was
the it was the it was a vehicle that was
being prepared for Alan Shepard at the
Cape behind it you see the very large
gantry we said I've overpowers it which
was which was backed off so that some
tests could be run but when when work
was to be done on either redstone or the
or the mercury vehicle it'd be rolled up
into place now is some foreboding the
White House allowed the mercury
suborbital flight to proceed and on May
5th Alan Shepard became a whorl figure
by traveling six hundred and thirty
miles downrange in 15 minutes the Webb
McNamara meeting it took place at the
Pentagon a following day had the benefit
of the world reaction to Shepards
completely open televised flight he was
agreed by the two of them that all
missions should be conducted openly and
also that prestige was a valid national
goal it was felt that the Soviets would
soon be able to fly with multiple crew
and that proved to be correct
he might soon be able to actually fly
out around the moon or even go into
circumlunar flight around the moon but
it was also believed that they did not
have would not have the capability for
an extended period and with new
equipment to actually land on the moon
so so at this point let me just show you
what happened to just about the time
that the that this report was to be
handed in to the Vice President Johnson
and then to Kennedy there was a meeting
out of the front and the back of the
White House where President Kennedy gave
Alan Shepard the highest award that NASA
can give and behind Alan is his
beautiful wife now thanks in part to the
success of Shepards flight the President
and Vice President accepted the
go as did the Congress following
President Kennedy State of the Union
address on May 25th 1961 now to achieve
this goal policy issues had to be
resolved and quickly and one of one of
them had to do with with NASA personnel
build-up and a decision was made that
the necessary build-up and capability
around the country would not come by
increasing substantially the number of
people at NASA rather major support
would be required from many other
departments and agencies of government
for the Air Force for example played a
major role from a large number of
contractors and I forget the number but
it was staggering and from foreign
nations particularly those nations that
that were located where we wanted to put
large tracking antennas now the space
Task Group which had been a thousand
strong not at Langley field where the
astronauts were being trained and where
the where the design of the mercury was
taking place was moved to Houston Texas
and became the manned spacecraft Center
and and and now the Johnson flight
center new operations were started in
New Orleans for assembling the first
stages of the Saturn booster and in
Mississippi for testing large rocket
engines and boosters a tremendous amount
of engineering was required obviously I
believe it's true that every engineering
discipline was brought into play from
pile-driving in the in the Florida sands
to support those to become the second
largest building in the world to the
study of orbital mechanics for transfer
of astronauts from lunar landing to for
example the orbiting craft going around
the moon with Mike Collins aboard as it
turned out now I'm going to discuss for
you three aspects of the engineering
decisions that had to be made first a
mode selection for achieving lunar
landing and return second a message
method for assembly and check-out at
Cape Canaveral and third the strategy
for evolving development
hardware into flight ready launch
vehicles as rapidly as possible and as
safely and reliably as possible I kneel
in the other hand is going to talk about
the design requirements for the lunar
landing you'll get into the subject of
the rocket engines you'll get into
guidance and navigation as well as a
subject of training and the simulation
and the special age that were required
for the crew before they made their
first of a kind mission so now turning
to the the mission itself and how is to
be accomplished the favored mode in
those days you know followed the Jules
Verne script of a takeoff with all
equipment aboard in this version called
direct ascent you peeled off booster
stages as you as you required more and
more acceleration so this happened as
the trip progressed arriving back home
aboard the capsule that had been a home
away from home for the whole journey a
variant on its approach involved placing
the hardware and propellants in Earth
orbit through a series of two or more
launches several several stages or
modules could be launched separately
connected together in Earth orbit after
rendezvous and docking much as in plant
much as as a space station has been
planned today
the astronauts once they were in Earth
orbit would then proceed to the moon and
back just as though they'd taken off
direct descent however there was a
strategy proposed by John who vault and
NASA research engineer which is quite
different in this mode the astronauts
traveled to the moon with two separate
habitats one spacecraft would stay in
orbit around the moon the other the
lunar lander would separate from this
spacecraft to land on the moon after
visiting a lunar surface the astronauts
would lift off from the moon rendezvous
and transfer to the
turn spacecraft what did this seemingly
more complex and possibly more dangerous
approach have to offer I mean I was
posing you don't rendezvous and dock the
obvious answer was to limit the launch
requirement the return spacecraft
required a heavy heat shield to protect
the astronauts during high-speed reentry
the requirement to land then accelerate
the return spacecraft back into lunar
orbit if we done it that way would have
doubled the size of the launch vehicle
at takeoff from Cape Canaveral more
detailed design brought out additional
advantages the lunar lander could be
configured for maneuverability and and
and crew visibility in the in in the
vacuum and as approach the moon where
the visibility was clearly very
important and Neill will be discussing
that with you shortly but obviously all
was lost if the astronauts failed to
rendezvous
I didn't say dock because the astronauts
were trained to transfer to the return
capsule by evie a extra vehicular
activity if docking failed and the
return vehicle would also be maneuvered
for a rendezvous
if the lunar lander happened to run out
of gas or something went wrong assuming
it was up in orbit these aspects of the
mission were practiced extensively on
Gemini missions that preceded Apollo and
in simulated Apollo flights on one one
at one flight Gemini six rendezvous with
with with Gemini seven but we flipped
the numbers it was much more fun to talk
about the 76 mission rather than the 67
mission here you see a Gemini 7 with
Frank Frank Borman and Jim Lovell aboard
and they took off from a pad they were
going to fly for 14 days anyway and the
idea was that in about 7 days if we work
posthaste night and day we could get
Gemini 6 and it's a Titan booster on the
pad and it could take off and we could
demonstrate rendezvous and
but not docking well obviously this did
take place there's little trouble at the
takeoff we had to delay a couple of days
but they not only were able to come
reasonably close they differ as to how
close they came but I believe the
measurement was made in centimeters no
the the extra vehicular was actually
tested on first on Gemini 4 and here you
see ed white outside the capsule and he
found that once he got outside he had a
little a little hand rocket gun and he
could aim it in different directions and
and move back and forth and the idea
here was that if all else failed if you
didn't dock you'll be possible for the
transfer to take place by going out of
one capsule and coming into the other
now finally the added risk had to be
viewed in the context of total risk
weighing the pros of a smaller launch
vehicle at Cape Canaveral
maneuverability and visibility near the
moon and the advantage of to inhabit of
inhabitable vehicles each with its own
life support against the greater risk
associated with rendezvous of two
vehicles in orbit around the moon now
there were there were many differing
views on this both within and and and
without NASA let me say and a brain at
Holmes who headed the man program at
that time and Joe Shea the systems
architect who worked with him ran all
kinds of analyses and to try to get a
better feel for which was the best of
these emission approaches and while all
this was going on and before a decision
had been made President Kennedy and Vice
President Johnson decided they'd like to
go and visit the various centers
involved in the in the program and the
first stop was Huntsville and we ended
up very early on inside of the large
assembly hangar that's there and here
you see the entourage with President
Kennedy on the left you can see the Vice
President Johnson looking a little
gloomy
facing us and on his on his right as Jim
Webb talking to Wernher von Braun
there's a spy looking over somebody's
shoulder there and and then you have a
Secretary of Defense McNamara Jerry
Wiesner and Howard brown Jerry Wiesner
at that time was President Kennedy's
science advisor and Kennedy was very
interested in so the intellectual
aspects of things and right on the floor
here of the this big building he started
asking about the pros and cons the kind
of thing we've just been discussing and
there's a roped-off area and a whole
bunch of press and everything on the
other side of the rope and they could
see this earnest discussion and Liza's
say there was plenty of probing by the
press after this had taken place but
when all the dust settled and everything
was taken into account reason prevailed
and the Apollo mission was conducted by
lunar orbit rendezvous
now all previous space vehicles had been
assembled on a launch pad and when
latched the ground team usually about
250 strong we're as close as you could
get them and to have them close and have
it safe they had lots a
reinforced-concrete over their heads so
the only way they could get information
as to what was really going on was by
looking through a submarine type
telescope or by reading a whole bunch of
dials and when we and in order to
proceed you had to take the the vehicle
stage by stage first stage on the pad
and the next in the next Welcome
altogether test it out and why are you
doing this you might have tremendous
sand storms rain hail lightning all
kinds of things and it was just as we
thought about it as we and we tried to
plan how we're going to assemble the
Saturn 5 which was many many times more
larger and more complex than anything
we've been before it was just daunting
to think of doing it out of doors and
and for that reason we thought thought
we should assemble indoors but of course
then you run up against the very the
very obvious problem how are you going
to get it on the page
and also how are you going to check it
out and here you see the Saturn 5 and
the Apollo on the transporter now how
did the transporter come to look like
that incidentally in the distance you
can see the vertical Assembly Building
that very large building I mentioned
earlier now in the past when we move the
gantry back and forth it ran on wheels
and so we thought why not we just put a
lot of track down in wheels and no
matter how many wheels we put on we
found that if you stop the transporter
overnight you had flats on the wheel the
next day the loads was so great then we
we thought well we got a lot of water
down at the Cape and we can just build
some canals and we have floated out and
and and and the and there wasn't a
marine type engineer who could figure
out how to keep the hull Cluj stable if
you tried it that way so things with
titan look pretty bleak the whole
concept of an assembly bearing a
building appeared to be going out the
window when the von braun team
discovered the enormous drag lines that
are used for surface mining of coal in
Appalachia the low is carried by the
caterpillar tractors and you can see
perhaps the 3 or 4 of them there we're
carrying loads that were comparable so
what Apollo Saturn would weigh along
with its umbilical Tower and and along
with the platform itself and the drag
lines had had automatic leveling
obviously an important feature and
particularly important since to get out
to the pad three miles away this whole
ensemble whole assembly had to go up a
three degree slope however the use of a
transporter introduced other problems
until 1962 as I've described everybody
isn't a blockhouse and what you use
there for instrumentation is what you
use practically at home you had
thermometers and and
wires perhaps coming out inside
voltmeters to read and so on but there
was no way that you could connect
directly from the sensors on the on the
Apollo and the Saturn directly in to the
large control here three miles away the
the solution necessitated the conversion
of analog to digital signals never
before had so many sensors and convert
has been required the same devices were
to be used for checkout and for
launching which was also important at
large on the order of 70,000 signals
were automatically verified during the
file two minutes before a liftoff and if
the signals were not within tolerance
the launch crew would investigate and
determine whether to scrub or continue a
whole extensive digital processing and
computing equipment was installed in the
base of the transporter to provide all
the necessary information for the
checkout and large cruise where the
vehicle was in assembly or sitting on
the launch pad and you can see their
individual consoles and and at each
console you had somebody who is a
specialist in the particular area that
the that the instruments were measuring
and if anything appeared to be out of
Tolerance the light would go on to tell
a fellow to get alert of the gal to get
alert and and by means of the instrument
of the of the computer and so on you
could zero in and find what the fault
was and and or if you couldn't fight it
you certainly were going to we're going
to hold or scrub if you could find it
there were occasions when something
would be slightly over tolerance and you
could go ahead now the last item I want
to discuss is what I've called all up
testing technologies enters into design
decisions in many obvious ways but it
also effect affects optimal developments
often in such a subtle fashion a rocket
propelled vehicles have experienced many
failures pride of success went back to
the beginning
I understand it was a seventy-first
firing of the v2 before the Germans
achieved success at peenemünde II and
thank goodness that was the case as a
consequence the planning for the Saturn
with the von braun team in charge called
for four launches of the first stage
before going to the second stage so that
you get the first stage under control
and then you'd move on to the next now
all four were successful and by the time
saturn was it's called sa 3 and sa four
came along the press got wind of this
that we had a quite a time with a meteor
explaining why we had to spend all this
money to carry tons of sand across the
Atlantic Ocean that's about all we're
accomplishing now just just prior to the
launching of sa 5 President Kennedy who
was staying at Palm Beach said he'd like
to come over and see how things were
going on with his friend senator
smothers and and hear you here you see
him that's the that's that's a cement of
the Secret Service behind Wernher von
Braun and here you see President Kennedy
and and President Kennedy is is pointing
up at the SI five and a model of it was
used for explanation and that's right
next to Werner and if you want to see it
in the flesh and go to the Kennedy
Library where that very same model now
rest but what we're explaining to
President Kennedy was that the next
launching which actually occurred about
six weeks later had a live upper stage
it's called the s4 stage for very
complicated reasons but it's really the
second stage would be the first time
that we tried in a major way to make use
of hydrogen as a fuel now you can see
that if we were going to proceed step by
step this way we had a long road to go
before we got to full-scale launching
with astronauts aboard of the saturn v
now george miller when he came aboard
all right
these questions in a dramatic fashion he
stated we couldn't reach our goal step
by step we must test as much hardware as
possible on each mission all up testing
became the watchword the first flight of
a saturn v and included all three rocket
stages and the Apollo capsule with a
service module the official designation
was Apollo 4a s 501 all systems were go
at lunch right on time
November fourth nineteen second sixty
seven nobody aboard of course and all
continued to perform essentially
perfectly during the entire flight and
there you see the Apollo Saturn for the
first launch of the Apollo Saturn and
it's almost read the bottom has almost
reached the top of the umbilical tower
you can see those swing arms of our back
away from the vehicle and this is at the
point when since the three mile distance
to the spectators and to the large
control when you could first hear the
sound of those rocket motors and it was
really intense when I say here you
didn't just hear them with your ears you
could feel it in your chest and you fell
it all over the roar of those engines
and the vibrations were really fantastic
but this the principle of all our
systems testing was established by this
daring but essential plan made possible
by greatly improved component
reliability and company and
comprehensive testing this is one of the
reasons that we had across the
Mississippi test facility now as I have
mentioned earlier Neil Armstrong will
discuss certain engineering aspects of
the lunar landing from quite a different
perspective than mine
Neil's view was that of a very
interested and technically minded user
he was the first to conduct a successful
docking when it when he piloted Gemini 8
and docked with the Agena and that's the
whole story in itself and that was a
very exciting experience he ended up
spinning when the thing went out of
control at two revolutions a second and
he pulled his way out of it he then
landed eagle in the Sea of Tranquility
with Buzz Aldrin at his side they worked
together as a team obviously followed by
a docking with Mike Collins aboard
Apollo 11 spacecraft in lunar orbit and
then he went through a very high-speed
reentry to return back into the Earth's
atmosphere and for his remarkable skills
demonstrated live before millions of
people he earned the privilege of
addressing August groups like the one
I'm showing you here the joint session
of Congress and and here you see Neil
buzz on the right Mike on the left vice
president Agnew and the speaker
McCormack and and now the shoe is on the
other foot we here are privileged to
have Neil with us today to tell us some
of the engineering aspects of his flight
thank you
jacket
that's a very kind welcome and I'm most
appreciative I'm appreciative to be
asked to to give the gardener lecture as
I look on the back of your program at
the list of former lectures I'm struck
that there are some of the most able and
creative leaders in in aviation and
aerospace in in our history and the
honored that Bob and I would be asked to
add our names to that list
Bob said I'm going to talk a little bit
about the engineering aspects of the
lunar landing and you can of course find
the thousand kinds of engineering
challenges and solutions to talk about
so I thought I would highlight just that
part of the flight which was involved in
getting from from lunar orbit to the to
the surface of the Moon the requirements
were were relatively simple begin in
lunar orbit and end up parked on the
surface hopefully in a suitable
condition to take off again it was
desirable to be able to land at a
pre-selected location without runways
without control towers beacons or any
other aids on the surface each of the
sites that we would like to go to would
be selected to investigate different
types of lunar topography to photograph
and sample the Highlands and the craters
in the Mari
after selecting a landing site it's
longitude and latitude could be
accurately determined from lunar maps
drawn from astronomical photographs
elevations relative to the mean surface
level was considerably less certain a
landing site near the equator certainly
has advantages equatorial orbits would
pass over or near the landing area on
every revolution and would give the
flight planner a good deal of
flexibility because the landing site
must lay underneath lie underneath the
orbital path or near it a site well
north or south of the equator requires
an inclined orbit the moon's rotation
about its axis is about a half a degree
per hour and so the landing site is
always moving toward or away from an
inclined orbit adding constraints to the
trajectory plan the fact that
earth-based radar could provide accurate
spacecraft position and velocity
information at lunar distance was a
substantial engineering achievement of
course the rotation of the earth meant
that the radar itself was moving at
substantial speed additionally half of
the time it was on the side of the earth
away from the moon and could not be
utilized so three giant radars were used
more or less equally spaced around the
earth so that at least one of them was
always located in a position to give
good coverage of the spacecraft because
the entire orbit around the moon
subtended only a half a degree as seen
from Earth some amount of tracking time
was and mathematical smoothing was
required to establish an accurate value
for the three orthogonal components of
position and the three orthogonal
components of velocity these six vectors
with the Associated time tag was known
as the spacecraft state or state vector
it could be accurately determined and
projected ahead in coasting flight but
wasn't unable to keep up whenever the
spacecraft was changing its trajectory
due to rocket thrust in 1966 the
trajectory planners were given an
unwelcome surprise it happened during
the flight of an American robot
spacecraft named lunar orbiter the first
craft to fly around the moon its orbit
as recorded by the giant radars here on
earth
had some peculiar Wiggles in it whenever
the spacecraft flew over one of the dark
areas our Mari it was attracted inward
toward the moon the only known cause for
such a phenomenon would be an
extraordinarily strong gravitational
pull due to the very heavy spots on the
moon's surface these mass concentrations
or mass Khan's were mapped by analyzing
the orbit of the lunar orbiters and
later by the or mapping the the orbit of
Apollo 8 the first manned craft to fly
around the moon which occurred during
the Christmas of 1968 and again on
Apollo 10 the lunar landing dress
rehearsal his orbit Wiggles were quite
pronounced indicating that the mass cons
were quite near the lunar surface there
was substantial concern that these
gravitational uncertainties would
preclude landing at a precise location
on the surface nasa's landing trajectory
specialists in houston ran many
trajectories with the varying levels of
Muskaan influence they concluded that
the masks on effects were acceptable
additionally they considered aspersions
in inertial guidance alignment in rocket
engine performance to possible
conditions were to be considered a
successful completion of the landing or
a discontinuance of the approach during
the descent for any one of a variety of
reasons the dispersions should not
prevent the successful execution of
either in the case of the abort back to
orbit the dispersion should not put the
lunar module in a trajectory that would
make a subsequent rendezvous with the
command module impossible the rocket
engine to be used in the descent was
critical there would be a substantial
advantage in using a minimum weight
system wait was that a real premium as
bob has discussed that would dictate
high chamber pressure and high energy
propellants top candidates would be
liquid hydrogen as the fuel and liquid
oxygen as the oxidizer these propellants
were cryogenic it is they had to be kept
at very low temperatures to maintain the
liquid phase and it was a four-day trip
to the moon and there was a chance of
substantial evaporative loss during the
trip an alternate possibility was to use
propellants that were liquid at normal
temperatures fuels such as alcohol or
kerosene hydrazine oxidizers such as
hydrogen peroxide or
nitrogen tetroxide the combination
eventually was selected was a hydrazine
udmh blend as the fuel and nitrogen
tetroxide as the oxidizer now both of
those are liquids at normal atmospheric
pressures and temperatures but they're
very toxic and nasty
to work with they had been in common use
for rockets for decades however in their
nature however unpleasant was well known
and understood combination had an
important advantage they were hypergolic
that is they the fuel burned whenever it
came in contact with the oxidizer they
were self-igniting so there was no need
for spark plugs or other special
ignition devices or other systems
additionally the combination had
reasonable specific impulse or energy
efficiency at relatively low chamber
pressures that permitted a pressure fed
rocket that did not require the weight
and complexity of a turbo pump to boost
the pressure the resulting combination
was conceptually simple and reliable
however there was one other requirement
that was everything but simple somehow
this rocket needed to provide a wide
variation in thrust to efficiently
decelerate from orbital velocity
required a high thrust level landing
required a relatively low thrust level
orbital speed in lunar orbits
approximately 5,500 feet per second now
some of you will be surprised by my
archaic use of English units
although new metric RSI was used in a
few places in NASA in those days English
units were the predominant standard and
because this is an engineering history
lecture I'll use the English units that
were the norm at the time using Newton's
law and the second law and the
definition of rocket specific impulse
one can readily determine the propellant
required to decelerate a mass from orbit
to zero velocity we leave it as an
exercise for the student for the lunar
case each for each pound to be delivered
to the surface requires slightly more
than a pound of our selected propellant
so the initial weight in orbit must be
more than twice the landing weight when
the craft was landing or hovering above
the surface preparing to land the thrust
would need to be equal to the landing
weight plus some modulation to allow for
increasing and reducing the rate of
descent while maneuvering for landing
most of rocket engines of that era were
operated at essentially fixed thrust
throttle engines were very rare and
those that had been tried had far less
modulation than would be necessary the
engineering challenge was substantial
two contending approaches were tried one
concept use an inert gas into the
propellant it inserted in our gas into
the propellant line between the tanks
and the rocket so that the thrust would
be reduced while the total flow rates
through the combustion chamber would be
constant at all times the competing area
are competing idea used a mechanical
throttling system using cavitating
venturi flow control valves
that engine which was built by STL later
to become TRW was selected for the lunar
module but actually both approaches
worked quite well surprisingly well the
engine had a maximum thrust of 10,000
pounds and could be modulated between
1000 and 6000 pounds the thrust needed
to hover before landing was about 2,500
pounds and the variation available then
1 to 6000 was adequate for that task in
the thrust region between maximum thrust
and and the throttling range the
cavitating then Therese would be
intermittently cavitating or not and
produce an unpredictable mixture ratio
the thrust that thrust range was
prohibited to us due to the probability
of excessive erosion of the nozzle
simplicity and reliability were selected
over performance the rocket is the
simple pressure fed system the
propellants were pushed into the rocket
by gas pressure helium stored in a
supercritical state at about 1600 psi
and that was used to pressurize the
tanks at about 235 psi maximum chamber
pressure in the combustion chamber was a
remarkably low 103 psi at maximum thrust
and considerably less in the throttling
region there were many engineering
accomplishments in the Apollo program
but many believe the descent engine was
one of the most outstanding for guidance
navigation and control the lunar module
had an inertial guidance system designed
here at the Draper lab which at that
time was called the instrumentation
laboratory the system included a three
degree of freedom and Herschel
measurement unit and a digital computer
the IMU was the navigation
sensor using accelerometers and gyros to
sense attitude and velocity changes a
computer which included the navigation
logic for calculating the guidance
commands was a 70-pound
16-bit machine at 36 K Arum and woven
woven rope cores had no color monitor
not even a black and water white monitor
no alpha numerics all communication to
and from the operator was through three
registers of seven digits two for
identification and five for data by
today's work stamp workstation standards
or even in comparison with a Mac or PC
it was a primitive device but it was far
advanced over anything we had had up to
that time
and we were delighted to have it even
though it cost more than a small country
the orbital altitude selected to
initiate the powered descent was 50,000
feet descents from altitude above 50,000
feet required increasing amounts of
propellant and altitudes below 50,000
feet increasingly reduced safety margins
altitude errors in either direction
could prevent guidance equations from
converging and would prevent a
successful landing the moon of course
has no atmosphere the normal flight
instruments of an aircraft the altimeter
airspeed indicator Mach meter rate of
climb are all atmospheric sensing
devices and will not operate in a vacuum
but clearly such information directly
measured would be of considerable use to
the crew so a specially designed radar
attached to the lunar module was used to
determine altitude and velocity the
landing radar directed four beams to the
lunar surface a three beam Doppler
velocity sensor and one beam for the
determination of slant range with
appropriate coordinate transformations
the results could be converted into
altitude and three components of
velocity all relative to the surface
because the radar beams were traversing
an irregular in even mountainous surface
the radar data was jumping and required
some smoothing within the guidance
computer and I'd mentioned a lot about
two guys at the at the Draper lab or the
instrumentation lab who were in in large
way responsible dick bet and then George
cherry-picks here today and many of you
all here today I'm sure helped NIC and
George with those projects and
and we remember that work and very well
and with a great deal of respect the
descent trajectory was divided into
three parts
the breaking phase the approach phase
and the landing phase the breaking phase
was intended to provide deceleration
from orbital velocity down to something
under 1,000 feet per second best fuel
efficiency dictate that that be
conducted at maximum thrust as we've
discussed the breaking phase covered
slightly more than 200 miles in about
eight and a half minutes the last two
minutes utilized the lower throttling
region of the of the engine to allow for
Corrections of dispersions in engine
thrust and in trajectory the braking
phase was designed to place the lunar
module at about four and a half miles
short of the landing site at an altitude
of about seven thousand feet from this
point the approach phase was initiated
here the cruise should be able to pick
up visual contact with the planned
landing site the guidance logic which
could be characterized as downrange
acceleration command which was a
quadratic function of time was designed
to bring the craft down to 500 feet just
short of the landing point from this
point the autopilot could complete an
automatic touchdown or the crew could
maneuver to the preferred landing
location in actuality the crews were
reluctant to commit to an automatic
landing the auto pilot had no way of
picking out the smoothest landing area
and it was not protected against landing
with one landing pad sticking in a
crater analytical studies had indicated
7% of automatic landings would overturn
on touchdown so it's not not surprising
that the Apollo landings where land were
flown manually
now I put this diagram in because when
I'm when I was teaching these these are
the quality of the slides I used to use
because of the reduced gravity a machine
hovering over the moon as shown in the
middle there would require only
one-sixth of the vertical thrust it
would need hovering over earth as on the
left side so while slowing to a hover
the forward component of that of that
thrust is consequently only one-sixth of
its value on earth and likewise the
deceleration is only 1/6 so to obtain
the same translational acceleration or
deceleration as you would get in an
earth on the left there requires
attitude changes as shown on the far
right side that are approximately six
times larger than would be required on
earth traversing large pitcher role
angles of course either requires more
time or larger control powers it was
expected that the control
characteristics ideal here on earth
would not at all be acceptable
acceptable on the moon these concerns
had been the subject of much attention
in the years immediately prior to the
landing attempt a variety of studies and
simulations had been conducted attitude
changes in roll and pitch in yaw were
assumed to be achieved by the use of
small attitude control rockets in the
ground-based flight simulators pilots
found that they could control attitude
well with reaction control rockets but
they encountered difficulty in making
precise landings and eliminating
residual velocities at touchdown
it was clear that something nearer to
the real flying experience was needed
helicopters were tried they could hover
and they could duplicate the final lunar
landing trajectory unfortunately they
were incapable of investigating the
problems of moe
concern they could neither replicate the
consequences of the lunar gravity or the
handling characteristics of reaction
control system machines fortunately
there were two projects which were very
effectively filled the void the lunar
landing research vehicle LL RV and the
lunar landing research facility ll RF
the LL RV was developed by NASA's Flight
Research Center at Edwards California
and built by the Bell Aircraft Company
in the lunar simulation mode the
turbofan engine mounted in a double
gimbal was aligned to the local vertical
and the thrust adjusted to 5/6 of the
LRV weight the equivalent of the lunar
module descent engine was provided by a
pair of throttle able 500 pound thrust
rockets fixed to the fuselage outside
the gimbal ring
these were mono propellant rockets using
a hydrogen peroxide as a fuel the
turbofans angle and thrust could be
modulated to compensate for aerodynamic
drag so that the craft coasted as if it
were flying in a vacuum the LL RV had a
very lightweight structure and
encountered a variety of interactions
between controls and low structural
frequencies after a number of
development changes were incorporated
this cleverly compensated flying machine
actually managed to closely duplicate
flying as if it were over the moon and
became a very useful tool for
understanding the needs of flying in the
lunar environment at the NASA Langley
Research Center an alternate approach to
a lunar simulation was initiated in what
they called the lunar landing research
facility don't have a slide I'm sorry
but you can imagine a craft like one of
those stick figures I I drove suspended
by cables from a large gantry
the idea again was to duplicate the
lunar gravity and control
characteristics the method was to lower
the vehicle apparent weight to its lunar
equivalent by lifting upward on the
vertical cables attached to a traveling
bridge cake cream in a complex
electro-hydraulic system kept the crane
platform directly over the machine and
with an upward force equal to 5/6 of the
vehicle weight even during translations
and angular motions and weight changes
during due to fuel usage it had a
wonderful combination of structural
cable stretch pendulous frequencies
requiring innovative compensation
techniques it indeed was a mechanical
engineers dream the vehicle was attached
to the cables through gimbal rings
allowing pitch roll and yaw motion
provided by hydrogen peroxide rockets
and the 1/6 vehicle weight not lifted by
the cable system was lifted by a
throttle a bull hydrogen peroxide rocket
fixed to the structure after the kinks
worked that were worked out it it worked
surprisingly well
the flying volume which was about 180
feet high 360 feet long and 42 feet wide
was somewhat limiting for a pilot but
adequate to give a substantive
introduction to lunar flight
characteristics both the L LRV and the
ll RF were able to investigate a wide
range of control characteristics
controlled system parameters were varied
an optimum combinations recommended
primarily based on pilot opinion both l
lr v and l l RF studies indicated that
much lower control powers were
acceptable than had been expected based
on VTOL aircraft and helicopter
experience it was a welcome surprise
because low control powers result in low
attitude control fuel consumption these
and related evaluations were most useful
in establishing the actual lunar module
control configuration the final lamb
attitude control system was rate command
attitude hold that is the control stick
commanded angular rate in all three axes
but when centered attitude was
maintained based on the studies I've
just been talking about pitch and roll
control power had been established at
eight degrees per second and maximum
commanded rates at 20 degrees per second
handling 20 degrees per second for the
lunar module and that that provided
handling qualities that were remarkably
good in the ll RV here the the rocket
was directly controlled by the throttle
but the lunar module the real lunar
module added an automatic throttle that
would modulate thrust to maintain a
constant descent rate workload was
substantially reduced and gave the pilot
more time to concentrate on selecting a
suitable landing spot a number of
concerns regarding lunar flying emerged
that were unrelated to the hardware for
many decades astronomers were mystified
by the peculiar reflective qualities of
the moon
these are surprisingly large changes in
brightness and sun angle and a very
bright spot along the Sun line it was
feared that visibility visual acuity and
depth perception during a lunar landing
could be severely degraded
throughout the Apollo program
development there were worries about
visibility degradation due to dust
clouds caused by the high velocity
rocket exhaust impinging on the lunar
surface
additionally rough country a closer
Eisen and lack of a strong sense of the
vertical were possible impediments to
precision flying
Lunar Module experienced normal design
evolution the cabin volume was changed
from spherical to cylindrical the
landing legs were reduced from 5 to 4
the window area was substantially
reduced and the seat was removed a
standing pilot or trolley conductor
cockpit reduced weight moved the pilots
eye closer to the window improving
visibility and improved the structure a
cable restraint system was devised to
keep the pilots in the proper position
in the cabin and to hold them secure
during landing loads the fears about
being blinded by the sun's reflection
were unfounded the right spot was there
but the human eye is quite capable of
accommodating to it and it did not
hinder operations the initial flights
landed early in the lunar morning that
provided long shadows which improved
depth perception lunar dust on the other
hand proved to be a substantial
impediment the dust was found not to
erupt in clouds as it would here on
earth it travels radially outward from
the exhaust impingement area in horror
horizontal thin flat sheets it's very
logical in the lunar vacuum that's a
most surprising phenomenon to earthlings
when the rocket engine stops the dust
immediately disappears over the horizon
leaving a perfectly clear view with no
dust cloud or other residual effects of
any sort as might be expected the dust
quantity varied from landing site to
landing site on Apollo 11
buzz and I had a dust sheet that was
opaque and that's a disconcerting due to
its rapid movement but boulders
protruding above it provided benchmarks
adequate for estimating speed and
altitude on Apollo's 1460
and 17 the dust was quite thin and
permitted visual reference to the
surface on Apollo's 12 and 15 however
the surface was completely obscured with
dust below 50 feet altitude and the
landings were completed essentially on
instruments all in all in in spite of
its ungainly appearance the lunar module
was a superb flying machine was a credit
to the engineering profession and to
those at Drummond TRW Draper lab and the
others who created it I'm in the debt of
all those folks and I thank you all for
the chance to join you today
[Applause]
I'm sure our speakers would be happy to
take a few questions if maybe I could
invite Bob and Neil to come back the
podium and I'll sit down and I would
like to ask that those of you who want
to ask questions come forward the
microphones because this is being
televised across the campus cable TV
system and we'll have a couple questions
and then we'll we'll conclude it if
you're concerned at all that the that
funding with funding levels for the
space program in this country have left
it in decline or do you think that
things are moving along well from your
point of view that's a question that has
to do with history in the future and
it's really a bit outside the scope of
this lecture but I would just say that I
think all of us that have been involved
in these these programs over the past
quarter century or so I've been very
pleased with the things we have
accomplished we're a little disappointed
that more things aren't being initiated
unless new projects are are being
supported but I it's my hope that that's
that's a temporary situation the world
is full of hills and valleys and that
won't ever change
is there any feeling you have about
where programs should be where funding
should be directed or is there any
particular program or other programs
that you think should be priorities and
then I promise I'll let you get away
well I I think I'm I feel comfortable
arguing in favor of any one of a number
of new elements I'm not gonna use today
to pick one over the other I wonder if
he might be able to recount some of the
last moments up to the lunar landing
specifically I understand there was the
radar picked up a number of boulders
over your landing site and you had to
hover for quite a while and nearly ran
out of fuel and almost had to abort the
mission work you could recount how close
you were to aborting the mission in
someone's last moments not sure you'd
all hear that but the question was
directed toward the final part of the
Apollo 11 landing we're where we did
have some amount of divergence keep our
keep our minds occupied
fortunately Buzz was a master on the
computer and he was able to keep me from
worrying about that too much we were
flying into the computer the the auto
pilot was flying us into an area as I
said it couldn't know where it was going
and it picked a very rough spot a very
large crater
but that's the size of a football
stadium and that would have been
scientifically interesting but I think
both buzz and I both agreed that on the
first landing we ought to pick something
that was a little less challenging so we
looked for a smooth spot and that took
us a while to to get over to a smooth
spot and yeah we did use up most of the
fuel that we had but I wouldn't and.yes
had we had to fly very much farther we
might have had to abort back into orbit
but I can't say that I really was
concerned about that because we were
getting to get down fairly close to the
to the surface and even if we ran out of
fuel a lot as long as we had an attitude
control with the one 6gy we thought we
could absorb that bump okay so I really
I really believed that it probably
wasn't a significant concern although
buzz was worried about everything on the
vehicle I only had to worry about one
thing so he should ask him to speak for
himself have you ever played lunar
lander
I I have to admit I have not already
snot myself
he doesn't native I was curious as to
whether it was accurate thanks have you
but I'm sorry I was born in 1973 I was
wondering if you had any idea where
thoughts to whether people would be
walking on the moon during my lifetime
well I when I was your age I was
absolutely certain that no one would
walk on the moon in my lifetime
[Applause]
from the from the lecture and from
history it was pretty clear that lots of
systems were being tested at once as you
described how did that either people in
the program and the pilots how did that
approach to testing not maybe rigorously
testing each system independently how
did you react to that how what was the
reaction inside the program to that
that's perceptive question those of us
who had been involved in testing some
period of time before this were had
become advocates of of the step at a
time system that dr. Siemens discussed
and it was difficult for us to accept
the idea that we were going to test
everything at the same time past
experience with that kind of thing and
in the aeronautical business some of you
well know that when you fly a new
airplane that's also has a new engine
and also has a new autopilot and stuff
you usually have a lot of problems
because you like to have something solid
nevertheless what we didn't appreciate
at that point in time was the the
increased confidence level that could be
achieved by very diligent component
tests and systems testing before we got
to flight and that was a level of
concentration that we had not been
exposed to and didn't previously
[Music]
recognize the value
like I speak to the pilots view of all
up system testing but it really became
obvious that we we're not going to be
able to to proceed to a final conclusion
of the program by just putting on a
stage and then testing it in another
stage and flying it and so on but I
would say that we didn't didn't shift
over
in desperation I mean we we felt that we
went we were taking a reasonable risk
we obviously carried out the that first
Saturn 5 flight without anybody aboard
we weren't going to go to that extreme
but the component testing was it was
obviously important but there really and
I think important testing that had not
really been done so extensively before
was done down at the Mississippi test
facility where we were able to take take
the whole a whole stage and fire up all
the engines and you have to realize that
when you did that you had to control
seven and a half million pounds of
thrust and that was that was a pretty
gigantic test facility but we had we
were planning to do that anyway and by
increasing the level of that testing we
had we said we certainly had a lot more
confidence that what we're doing was
correct but I'll have to say that that
particularly that German teamwork were
quite dubious about it and they could
not believe it when that saturn v the
very first one went all the way were
downrange the where it's supposed to go
and everything fired the way it was
supposed to it was it was a major
accomplishment press wait just a little
bit lucky but that's also important when
you're running a program
well I I certainly sense that the
audience is joining me in thanking our
speakers today and our distinguished
guests a number of who I've not had a
chance to introduce to you that are in
the audience that contributed heavily to
the Apollo program you've been a
wonderful audience and thank you very
much for coming
[Applause]